Hey Alex, how are you?
Pleasure to meet you.
I have another bionics expert on hand so I thought I'd drop by.
Thank you.
Yes, a pleasure.
Nice bow tie, by the way.
Thanks.
How were your travels?
It's very good.
Well, I thought I'd bring one of my gauntlets and match it up with yours...
...and see if everything is copacetic.
Do you wanna have a look?
Sure.
Ready?
Yup.
Great.
Each one looks the same.
Actually, I think yours might be better than mine.
What do you say we both try 'em on.
Do a progress report.
Okay.
Do you know who that is?
Iron Man.
What's his name?
Robert.
Great!
I'm having a technical glitch.
As you can see, my light isn't working.
Half the time, I design one of these, it winds up breaking on me.
But what I do is I keep working on it.
Kinda like you're working on it with Albert.
He keeps working and working until he gets it right.
Yeah.
I think yours is still a little bit more right than mine because at least, you know.
The lights work.
Your light works, yeah.
Ah, look at that then.
It's a marriage of robotic technologies.
Bang, nailed it!
Love it.